[Music]
on this Tuesday night a possible new
timeline for the spread of the corona
virus the French hospital that retested
an old sample and found a positive case
back in December what other countries
are now being asked to do the Canadian
province flattening the curve to have to
have the people you have to have the
knowledge New Brunswick's winning
formula what lessons can other provinces
learn the costly consequences of Kovach
19 on food prices whose potential you
could be looking at eight to ten dollar
heads lettuce or $12 cucumbers why your
grocery bill could balloon and
seventy-five years after a defining
moment in history
quiet gratitude for Canada's role in
liberating the Netherlands
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with fresh mystery over
how long Kovac 19 may have been
circulating before it was first
identified evidence has emerged in
France of a positive case in late
December 4 days before China reported a
cluster of cases of pneumonia of unknown
cause in Wuhan the case in France came
to light after a hospital there retested
frozen blood samples from patients who
had pneumonia like symptoms and one of
those tests came back positive for kovin
19 the World Health Organization is now
urging other countries to retest old
blood samples - from suspicious cases
Redman Shannon has our top story tonight
i'm Arusha Mar looks back at a video of
his time in intensive care in late
December I thought it was the flu he
told French news channel bfmtv
he had a cough a headache and fever but
recovered and was discharged on December
29th
two days later China first reported
cases of pneumonia of an unknown cause
on January 23rd the epicenter city of
Wuhan was locked down and a day after
that the first case was confirmed in
Europe a French citizen who had been to
China the virus has since killed tens of
thousands in Europe in April a French
hospital decided to retest samples taken
from 14 patients who were tested for
pneumonia in December and January it was
a volume get the positive or
covetousness Novell said this altameyer
sample was the only one that tested
positive a backup test confirmed the
finding it potentially changes the
entire modelling for how covert 19
spread particularly because the 42 year
old hadn't even been to China it's not
surprising that's important because the
given the earliest cases of copán 19 had
symptoms all said already in early
December so it's possible that some of
the infected people traveled from Wuhan
to other countries at that time the
World Health Organization now wants
other countries to go back and test -
there's always a opportunity I think to
sort of go back further
even the
to test samples we haven't actually as
as I know it discussed that as yet but
that is potentially of of interest so we
can definitely take a look at that
professor Luke O'Neill is working on a
treatment for covert 19
he's reserving judgment until other
tests show the virus was outside of
China in December and science you might
call a wacky results you gotta wonder
what's going on there now one suspicion
is the sample was contaminated somehow
it's a positive sample from January say
the results will also be key to the
question of the virus's origin something
that has recently become a political
football between Beijing and Washington
Redman Shannon Doble News London
there is evidence tonight too that the
original strain of Kovach 19 has mutated
into a new more contagious strain the
study was done by researchers at the Los
Alamos National Lab in New Mexico it has
not been peer reviewed but is being
shared now to help those working on
vaccines it analyzed thousands of corona
virus sequences and found a new strain
appeared in February in Europe then
migrated quickly to the east coast of
the United States and has been the
dominant strain across the world since
mid-march
wherever the new strain appeared it
quickly infected far more people than
the earlier strains that came out of
Wuhan China here in Canada Quebec has
the most cases and the most deaths and
quebec's public health officer said
today they will now go back and
investigate suspicious cases in December
and January Quebec has over 33,000
confirmed cases and nearly 2,400 people
are known to have died from Kovach 19
that accounts for more than half of
Canada's 62,000 cases more than 4,000
people in Canada are known to have died
there are places though where the curve
is flattening bc reported just eight new
cases today the first single-digit
increase in months and new brunswick
after going 16 days without a new case
recorded one new one today but it's had
no deaths and only 119 cases tonight
Ross Lord looks at what lessons others
can learn from New Brunswick as the
pandemic was growing in other parts of
Canada
New Brunswick went more than two weeks
without recording a single new case of
covert 19 its a streak no one saw coming
and no one can fully explain do you have
to have the people you have to have the
knowledge it's especially impressive
when you compare New Brunswick to its
neighbors on April 19th Quebec had just
topped 18,000 cases and has since almost
doubled Nova Scotia with a population
similar to New Brunswick's had about 700
cases and has since increased by more
than 300 on that same date April 19th
New Brunswick at just 118 cases and by
the end of Monday that number had not
budged marking 16 consecutive days
without a positive test even New
Brunswick's relatively low rate of
testing doesn't account for those
differences of course streaks don't last
forever so today we have a confirmed a
new confirmed case of kovat 19 our first
case since April 18th but all of those
118 year Brunswickers who tested
positive have recovered no one has died
health researchers credit several
decisions an early ban on students
returning to class if they've been on
March Break outside of Canada early
rules on self isolation and closing the
provinces border and two things New
Brunswick doesn't have a large urban
center and a major international airport
where you have international airports of
course there's much more opportunity for
that spread to get there in the
beginning and then continue with the
community-based spread the province was
first to ease social isolation rules and
allow 2 households to share the same
space but it won't relax border
restrictions its banning temporary
foreign workers even for farming and
fishing industries but we need to
protect our borders and I mean that's
been the whole discussion around the
temporary foreign workers it's it's not
about it's going to be inconvenient it's
about how do we minimize our risk health
authorities insist there could be
successive waves of the virus but at
least New Brunswick is looking forward
from a position of strength
Ross Lord mobile News Quebec is
promising new premiums and a bonus plan
for full-time health care workers in
hopes of recruiting more staff premier
France while ago announced the plan
during his daily
reefing but offer no specifics our
timeline says the province is down at
least eleven thousand two hundred
healthcare workers either because they
tested positive for Kovac 19 or they
fear getting it Montreal is transforming
some of its transit buses into mobile
testing clinics each one will be used to
test about a hundred people per day for
covin 19:00 and will be disinfected
regularly the buses are part of a
citywide effort to boost testing there
have been over 16,000 confirmed kovat 19
cases in Montreal that's about half of
Quebec's overall infections the federal
government is trying to ease the
pressure on Canada's farmers and food
producers Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
announced a two hundred and fifty two
million dollar aid package today to help
farmers and food processors hit hard by
the pandemic as Abigail Beeman reports
it falls far short of what the industry
says it needs out making meat deliveries
Michel Tremblay is glad to hear there's
some federal help for food processors
like him 77 million dollars for things
like personal protective equipment
but the day after the agriculture
industry told MPs they need this media
support the Prime Minister promised just
a fraction 252 million dollars in total
half is for producers facing extra costs
backlogs of livestock because of meat
processing plants slowdowns 100,000
extra cattle as one example we have the
food and the consumers that want the
food we just need little help getting
the food to the consumers and this is
not going to get it done it's quite
upsetting to a number of farmers who are
calling me now my phone is blowing up
because they're mad the support is not
there that we needed some in the pork
and poultry industry are considering
euthanasia for animals that cannot be
processed Keith Currie says there will
always be food on the shelves but
selection and price will be affected
you're looking at eight to ten dollar
heads of lettuce or $12 cucumbers he
knows where the price is going to settle
at in the fall if we don't see some
relief immediately this is an initial
and investment and if we need to add
more
we will Ottawa is also launching a 50
million dollar food surplus program to
buy extra food and get it to Canadians
in need through food banks we will be
working with the sector's that are most
impacted by have the biggest surplus
like for example poultry mushrooms
potatoes the Agriculture Minister is
encouraging farmers to take advantage of
the risk management programs already in
place but those farmers are saying
they've told the government for years
those programs aren't working in normal
circumstances let alone a pandemic
abigail Beeman global news Ottawa
pharmaceutical giant Pfizer has begun
human clinical trials of a potential
vaccine for Kovach 19 it was developed
in collaboration with a partner company
in Germany where trials began last month
the first phase involves 300 healthy
volunteers that could expand to 8,000
people in the second phase if these
trials are successful Pfizer hopes to
have a vaccine ready for emergency use
as early as September and possibly wider
distribution by the end of the year
there is no guarantee though most human
clinical trials
health experts say a reasonable
expectation for new vaccines to be
developed tested and manufactured is
about four years Russia is rapidly
becoming a kovat 19 hotspot and there
are mysterious cases now of doctors
falling from hospital windows
two of them were reportedly critical of
how underprepared Russia is for koban 19
and complained about a lack of personal
protective equipment a third doctor
who's in serious condition claimed he
was forced to work despite testing
positive Moscow has reported more than
10,000 new cases for three days in a row
the flight data and voice recorders from
the Canadian Forces helicopter that
crashed off the coast of Greece are
being analyzed in Ottawa the cyclone
helicopter went down April 29th while
returning to HMCS Fredericton from a
NATO training exercise the military says
it was within sight of the ship when it
went down in the water and there are
eyewitnesses who will be interviewed all
six people on board were killed four
aircrew and two sailors including sub
leftenant Mathew Pike from Nova Scotia
in a statement his family says he will
be remembered as a patriotic Canadian
and a true maritime er who wore his
heart on his sleeve he had a laugh which
could light up any room and could make
the best of any situation a ramp
ceremony will be held tomorrow at
Canadian Forces Base Trenton in Ontario
to honor him and the others who died
Canada's forest fire forecast coming up
why this year's season is expected to be
intense
this 48 storey skyscraper in the United
Arab Emirates was entirely engulfed in
flames and sent flaming debris to the
ground below at least a dozen fire
trucks responded and used drones to
fight the fire seven people are said to
have minor injuries in Canada about six
thousand wildfires burn every year and
this year Natural Resources Canada
predicts the season could be worse than
usual in some places Robyn Gill looks at
what to expect from west to east there
is still a dark line that shows how
close a fire came to destroying this
property the fire was basically right
here Maria jhope amove from Vancouver a
year ago to start a hobby farm in
Squamish this was her first fire ever
her property was spared but she's an AW
over how the flames encircled the farm
with little damage at the time that we
drove up it looked like a relatively
small fire we could just see smoke from
one of the properties and by the time
that we came back here within 30 minutes
the fire was in our backyard
it was mid-april when the flames
exploded in this part of BC's Squamish
valley no one expected it it's too soon
for fire season it's worrying them you
know I've heard people say well it's
always raining now it's wet we're okay
now that's a full sense of security
climate and forest experts are looking
at the models for eastern Canada the
summer weather is normal but take a look
at the red on the map you can see that
fire season is expected to explode to
well above average in June summer will
be fairly hot and dry in some places so
what are depictions lawyers for a
greater than average potential for fires
in most of Western Canada and the big
fires often smolder right into winter
there's less precipitation there and so
the ground is going to dry out faster
leading to you know entire fuels faster
and then as well just with predicted
temperature so that obviously plays a
big impact into how active a wild person
is that has Joppa on guard it was
nerve-racking enough when she heard that
for
crackling of flames for hoping that some
of the fuel was cleared by this fire and
that that will protect us over the
summer these fires become part of
Canada's landscape when summer arrives
and yet most are caused by people those
in natural resources and those who fight
these fires don't think that kovat 19 is
going to deter people from venturing out
and risking their lives on two fronts
the virus and these fires Donna Robin
Gill in Squamish BC thinks ahead is any
hand soap enough more of your questions
about Kovac 19 answered
[Music]
we're all cleaning more to protect
ourselves from Kovach 19 and more
Canadians are accidentally poisoning
themselves as a result
Health Canada says between February and
March there was a 58 percent increase in
accidental poisonings compared to the
same period last year
incidents involving bleach made up 38%
of all calls to poison control centers
in March this happens to be world hand
hygiene day washing your hands is still
the easiest most effective and
affordable way to prevent the spread of
disease and this year it's sparking
plenty of discussion and questions our
Jeff simple went to the experts to get
some answers my question is are all hand
soaps as effective as they need to be
any hand soap should work that is
assuming you use it correctly
studies suggest only around 5 percent of
us wash our hands the right way so we've
got German POW der which is used in some
environmental contamination studies to
show how germs can spread and I've
already rubbed some of this powder on my
hands assuming I touched a contaminated
surface but you can only really see it
in blacklight so I'm washing my hands
like I normally would with soap and
water front and back not really thinking
about it too much there we go
and lights out and you can see yeah I
missed a few spots we may not really rub
our thumbs or our fingertips which is
how we touch a lot of our surfaces this
doctor wrote a song to teach her own
kids the proper technique
[Music]
that song inspired this video and to
mark hand hygiene day it's now been
translated into 27 languages another
viewer asked when I go back to work
should I be worried about using a shared
washroom our germ powder shows the
potential for contamination if there is
a paper towel you can use a paper towel
to press the button that releases a soap
into your hand and you can wash your
hands and rinse them and everything
without without touching anything at all
and what about wearing gloves the gloves
can actually be more trouble than it's
worth and it can be a challenge to
remove your gloves without contaminating
your hand this Ottawa police officer
even tweeted this instructional video
pitch top bottom line if you want to
protect yourself the best way remains
the old fashioned way wash your hands
and if it helps sing a song Jeff sample
Global News Toronto
next in the Netherlands they never
forget this day and the connection to
Canada
I was 15 when the Nazis invaded the
Netherlands more than a hundred thousand
that Jews never came home our men were
put into forced labor by 1945 we were
starving
and then the Canadians capable and then
the Canadians came they helped liberate
the Netherlands from the Nazis that
heritage minute commemorates a deep and
abiding link between Holland and Canada
forged during the Second World War
on this 75th anniversary the gratitude
has felt as deeply as ever even as Mike
Armstrong explains if it can't be
expressed as openly there are no big
ceremonies at this the largest Canadian
War Cemetery in the Netherlands hundreds
of Canadians were supposed to have made
the trip over even Prime Minister
Trudeau planned to be on hand none of
that is happening and Alethea Assam is
down well one tradition still being kept
was on the eve of the anniversary a
speech by the Dutch King this town
square would usually have been packed as
the country remembered the 250,000 Dutch
people killed during the Second World
War
in the same town square seventy-five
years ago this week thousands celebrated
the end of the war as it turned out too
early German soldiers in a window opened
fire on the crowd and killed more than
30 Canadian troops made it into
Amsterdam the day after that shooting
they had fought for months and had
finally liberated the country but it
wasn't only freedom they brought years
under the boot of Nazi Germany had meant
starvation Canadians brought food as
well military historian David O'Keefe
says other countries remember Canada's
role during the two world wars but none
the way the Dutch do when you are
bringing food not only liberation from
political domination and ideological
domination but bringing the very basis
of life to them that is something they
will never forget a spirit of wild
Fiesta reigns and towns and villages
breed about the Canadian drive now there
aren't many left who were there but none
of the Canadians who were ever forgot
the reception sergeant norm Kirby says
after days of bitter battles one day he
was suddenly surrounded by children and
I just thought
while this is what it's all about this
is what I'm here for
seeing these kids and it just it's my
favorite picture of the war some of
Sergeant Kirby's friends were among the
more than 7600 Canadians killed fighting
in the Netherlands Mike Armstrong Global
News Montreal and that is global
national for this Tuesday I'm Donna
fries and we leave you tonight with the
sound of the bells on Parliament Hill
the 53 bells of the peace tower carillon
played a medley of dutch composed music
today to honor the sacrifice of
canadians who liberated the netherlands
and the lasting friendship thanks for
watching take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]